elodie travail pour les oies depuis cinq
ans une réserve privée complètement
inconnu du grand public
c'est une vieille famille d'anciens
colons britanniques qui la possède
depuis près d'un siècle
ici on est dans la réserve cinq étoiles
le palace du safari là où viennent des
millionnaires comme ces américains
on a vu des bébés autruches gazelles des
éléphants
des dizaines de kilomètres carrés de
safari rien que pour soi ça donne
forcément le sourire
john elliott est un new yorkais depuis
six ans il vient à les oies en famille
sont l'aude se trouve en plein milieu du
parc à l'intérieur que du luxe du bois
rare un lit à baldaquin une salle de
bain tout en marbre une piscine privée
et surtout une vue unique sur la vallée
pour cet homme d'affaires américain il
n'y a pas mieux au kenya
l'express ce parc est certainement le
plus cher mais ça reste abordable tout
est relatif dont les 800 850 dollars par
jour
mais il ya des gens qui veulent donner
plus pour soutenir le parc
qui veulent s'engager
qui donne peut-être 10 millions 100
mille dollars pour rester toute la
semaine
c'est probablement plus proche de 100
mille dollars
des riches donateurs voilà comment ce
sanctuaire écologique parvient à
maintenir un tel niveau de luxe et une
telle variété d'animaux
elodie veut nous montrer l'une des
espèces les plus rares de deua
des rhinocéros noirs il n'en reste que
trois mille dans le monde elle en a
repéré deux et pense que l'on peut s'en
approcher
mais il faut rester vigilant car à tout
moment ils peuvent charger
sûre d'elle elodie sort du véhicule et
va les réveiller même si elle connaît
bien leurs réactions elles restent
prudentes
je me rapproche pas trop près quand même
hein donc c'est si si c'est dangereux
mais comme ils sont apprivoisés à peu
près ces animaux donc si je vois un
signe ici commence à se réveiller je
cours vite
et lui c'est lola sont deux jeunes
rhinocéros elodie s'approche un peu plus
il ne reste qu'une dizaine de mètres
entre elles et les mastodontes qui ne
vont pas tarder à réagir
il laisse donc on va doucement mais donc
ça va ça va ça va et aucun signe
d'agressivité donc a pas de problème
quelques semaines auparavant c'est un
couple de rhinocéros noirs comme cela
qui a été abattu en plein jour à
quelques centaines de mètres d'ici des
braconniers les ont liquidé à coups de
kalachnikov ils les ont tués pour
revendre leur corne sur le marché noir
c'est une catastrophe c'est une
catastrophe parce que parce qu'en plus
ils les tuent pour rien parce qu'ils
pensent que la corne de rhinocéros en
ondes et ils s'en servent comme soi
disant comme médicament est en fait s'il
savait que la corne du rhinocéros est
comme un angle c'est exactement la même
chose donc si c'est
du gâchis c'est du gâchis pourtant la
direction de lewa a tout fait pour que
les communautés locales n'attaque pas la
réserve
tout autour les villages vivent en
grande partie grâce aux dons du parc une
politique qui a fait ses preuves enfin
jusqu'à ces dernières semaines
dans cette école pas moins de 500
enfants de 5 à 10 ans dans leur bel
uniforme bleu
vieil héritage colonial du système
éducatif britannique
c'est dans ces bâtiments en partie
refait à neuf ils sont scolarisés et
nourris gratuitement
[Musique]
même l'eau denrée ô combien rare est
vital dans la région coule à flots pour
leur plus grande joie
[Musique]
contrairement à leurs parents ils seront
bientôt lire et écrire mais dans ces
classes modèle les écoliers n'apprennent
pas que l'anglais ils apprennent aussi à
aimer leur gentil bienfaiteur le parc de
lewa
samoa et le directeur de l'école et il
sait parfaitement à qui il doit tout
cela
ces livres que l'on trouve ici ont tous
été achetés par les oies
et en même temps
ils nous ont acheté deux magnifiques
bureau
en fait même les locaux de cette école
ont été achetés par les oies et nous les
remercions pour tout ce qu'ils ont fait
pour nous
les livres les bureaux mais aussi les
professeurs tout ici est payé par le
parc
tous les enseignants sont formés et
sélectionnez paru
formés et payés grâce aux réserves
privées au tourisme c'est très bien mais
les kenyans ne s'en satisfont plus la
crise économique ainsi qu'une série de
sécheresse terrible on finit d'appauvrir
encore plus la population
ces enfants sont des privilégiés car
plus de 35% des kenyans vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté